when we hear the word public speaker we
have a really limited idea of who that
person would be
um so for me like i used to be very
phobic about public speaking and part of
the reason for it was because
i thought that being the per kind of
person i was
didn't equal being able to be a good
public speaker because you're only
imagining you know like the
super kind of out there showman
um
but i think there's another style of
public speaking that's more reflective
and
thoughtful and conveying ideas and
people like that too is there advice you
can give on how to overcome that like if
you're a shy person how to be a public
speaker i can totally give that advice
because
i used to before i would give speeches
you know if i had to do it in law school
if i knew like today was the day when i
was going to get called on in a law
school class i literally one time
vomited on my way to class that's how
nervous i used to be
um
and
yeah the way to do it is through
desensitization you know it's like been
figured out it's the way to overcome any
fear you have to expose yourself to the
thing you fear
but in very small doses
so
you can't start by giving the ted talk
you have to start i i started by going
to this class for people with public
speaking anxiety where on the first day
all we had to do was stand up and say
our name and sit down and like that's
the victory
that's fun to watch all those people
with anxiety just
okay that's the first step and then step
one step at a time yeah and then like
with this class you go back the next
week and
and he would have us come to the front
of the room and stand up with other
people standing next to us
so that you didn't have the feeling of
being all alone in the spotlight through
others sharing it with you and you would
answer some questions about where do you
grow up you know where do you go to
school
and you declare victory and you're done
and then little by little by little you
keep ratcheting up the exercises until
you get to the point where you can do it
and then you start having successes and
you realize oh you know actually i can
do this
what about like writing versus
improvising because i knew a few people
sort of the colleagues of mine that were
working on ted talks and
it feels like
you're supposed to like write the thing
like way ahead of time and you practice
it and they like help you and all that
kind of stuff
i don't think i've ever practiced the
speech once in my life or a lecture or
any of that like i know it's really good
to do but
is do you find
that relieve some of your anxiety
preparing well or are you now able to do
not preparing well at all um i
definitely like to prepare
before but
the kind of preparation that i've done
for my ted talks is completely different
from what i've done for everything else
because
ted talks are more like a theatrical
event where it's like a one-person show
and of course if you were gonna go on
broadway with a monologue you'd know
every word so it's kind of like that um
and so i would rehearse it over and over
the way you would do that
isn't that more anxiety like knowing
every single word it's so much anxiety
because yeah you're you're not even so
freaked out about being on stage so much
as what if i forget something yeah yeah
absolutely
i mean they do things like the last ted
talk i gave i actually did forget
something halfway through like i just
couldn't remember the next line um
and so i had to walk over like over
there where my notes yeah and
so i did that and the audience like very
kindly clapped while i did that and then
i came back to the spotlight and kept
going and they edit that out
so there's a failure mode that's okay
but still it seems really
it seems really stressful like i'm now
i'm not sure if i'll ever publish it but
i've been
[Music]
mostly just for a personal journey but
i've been working on
a series on wait for it hitler and the
third reich
sort of looking at the historical
context of everything because of my
family was so much affected by that
whole part of history so for me to
rigorously
i've read a lot about stalin and hitler
and for me to
force myself one of the best ways to
force yourself to really consider
material is to have to talk about it
totally yeah so that's that's why i'm
doing it but i'm playing with ideas of
some of it maybe like 20
is written down on paper
but the rest of it is my thoughts in the
moment
that's a difficult balance
to strike because if you write a lot
you're going to be more precise you're
going to
be more accurate
but you're going to miss some of the
deep
like honest emotion
the silences won't be correct
or the the silences between the words
won't capture
the depth of feeling unless if if you're
somebody like me if you're like i guess
that's what actors and actresses have to
do like
uh basically even though the script is
fully written you improvise between
the words between the lines
yeah but that's a skill well it also
takes so much time i mean i i experience
that with the ted talks it's like
you get to a stage so you're memorizing
everything word for word and at first
in that process it comes out in a really
wooden way the way you're saying like
the emotions gone but once you really
know it so you've internalized the words
then all the emotion comes back and you
can say them in a completely different
way you know and you're really speaking
it from the heart but you have to know
it so well
before you can do that
i would never recommend it because it's
just like it's so time consuming
you